Jennifer Lopez a totally taken us back
to the early 2000s with these looks it's
all for her new movie hustlers
[Music]
JLo plays a stripper in the upcoming
flick alongside a Riverdale's Lily
Reinhardt Julia Stiles party b-but yeah
baby I'm an actress now you are and a
crazy rich asian star constant whoo you
have the portable pole like JLo does
well I had one installed in my living
room
what well just for practice you know you
gotta do everything together into
character the movies based on a viral
New York magazine article about a crew
of its savvy strip club employees who
banded together to turn the tables on
their wealthy Wall Street clients from
what we've seen it seems like just a JLo
and constants are shooting right now but
we know they're co-stars we'll be
joining them on the New York set soon
JLo and party B no big dude yeah and
have you started filming with them yet
no and the favorite
how excited are you to work alongside
JLo and party B I missed the dream I
look at such a low so much I love party
I used to dance myself and so did party
so you know start up in the bottom now
we here
[Music]